here's an interesting sort of political
story it's a break this is a political
show it's a break from the virus
coverage and it's about Democratic New
York congresswoman Alexandria Casio
Cortez she's getting crushed by a
portion of the left a portion of the
left that widely supported her for a
long time at least until recently and
the reason AOC is getting crushed is she
is taking what she sees as a more
pragmatic approach to the progressive
movement and it's a really really
interesting story that has divided the
online progressive left over the last
few days this all started because there
are a whole bunch of primary challenges
by progressive Democratic candidates
against more centrist Democratic
incumbents AOC hasn't endorsed many of
those progressive challengers she's
chosen a couple of sort of easy ones in
Texas and Illinois where the opponents
are really conservative Democrats who
oppose abortion but otherwise aoc has
stayed out of a lot of these races AOC
has also had quite a bit of turnover in
her staff a lot of those sort of
outspoken young progressive activists
that were working for AOC have been
replaced with some more moderate
professional political strategist
Democrats that often work with incumbent
Democrats now there are questions
increasingly about whether AOC
campaigned enough for Bernie before
super Tuesday's results that that hurt
Bernie and the second Super Tuesday and
the third Super Tuesday and the virus
ultimately keeping people at home and
AOC has also publicly shifted from being
very antagonistic towards Nancy Pelosi
the Democratic Speaker of the House to
being more publicly laudatory and
positive towards Nancy Pelosi and a lot
of people have jumped on her for this
AOC has also jumped into criticizing
Bernie supporters for online harassment
that's been mostly the purview of
centrist Democrats and Biden supporters
and sort of DNC folks but AOC has said
yet a lot of that online harassment is
not good she said some of
Bernie's allies are two conflict based
that also rubbed a lot of Bernie
supporters the wrong way
AOC also launched a pact earlier this
year which is not looking to primary
centrist Democrats it's focused on
flipping red states to blue the the goal
of a o'seas pact is not to find centrist
Democrats and replace them it's to find
red seats and turn them blue replacing
Republicans with Democrats now I have to
tell you this makes me see a OC as much
more clever and shrewd politically as a
political operative than I imagined you
guys many of you criticize me
occasionally for saying hey you know AOC
has a lot of the right ideas but not the
right political practicality not the
right political approach I see that as
changing here now there's lots of people
that are furious about this TYT host
John Cougar has gone after AOC for this
a bunch of others have but let's think
this through first of all almost
everyone changes when they got elected
and and this is why I always say don't
defy or glorify individual politicians
they are all elected by the system we
currently have and essentially every
single one of them to some degree it
varies but to some degree when they
become elected officials under that
system they will start to reap reinforce
or defend to some degree some elements
of the system that got them elected once
they get into power that applies to just
about everybody it doesn't mean that
they flip and abandon their values
that's not what I'm saying but that's
not the important analysis for me the
important analysis for me is that we
just got done talking about Bernie lost
not because his ideas are bad but
because a lot of the people around him
are toxic because of his relationship
with those in positions of power because
the country just isn't as overtly left
as Bernie Sanders for the last six weeks
we've been saying many of us the future
of the progressive movement is in
somebody with Bernie sensibilities
Bernie's values many of Bernie's policy
goals but who has a better team around
them
fewer toxic people better branding none
of this democratic socialist stuff the
revolution language is not particularly
useful to Bernie aoc isn't changing her
political positions here her view on
medicare-for-all hasn't changed her view
on the green new deal hasn't changed
she's changing her approach maybe at
least that's what it seems like this is
what we've been talking about guys we
don't need someone who differs from
Bernie on core values Bernie has the
right core values AOC shares Bernie's
core values nothing has changed as far
as that goes
AOC is doing exactly what Bernie didn't
do a OSI is doing something to get
around what ultimately led to Bernie
getting crushed on Super Tuesday and
then more on Super Tuesday too and more
on Super Tuesday three people keep
saying hey we need Bernie's ideas with
better framing packaging and public
relations that's what a OSI is leaning
towards here a OSI is looking to become
a force for change by building these
relationships where in the next six
years eight years she could have a long
laundry list of legislative
accomplishments
she's working within the system to
invoke change now that's an area of
disagreement bernie has more of an
approach of destroying the system
revolution and then rebuilding it from
the ground up working within the system
has gotten us many important things gay
marriage Violence Against Women Act food
stamps Social Security Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau pre-existing
conditions coverage and being on your
parent's insurance until age 26 labor
laws birth control now has it been
enough no no way in hell has it also led
to bad things of course I mean you know
look at the Iraq war the Iraq war is the
epitome of working within the system
with centrist Democrats in great part
that got us the Iraq war but when icao
see step away from some of the
absolutism of Bernie my feeling is this
will help her get things done rather
than being able to say we tried this but
we failed we didn't actually get to do
it I believe this better position
AOC to actually get things done to me
this suggests a o C's political
instincts are better than I thought I
underestimated her political instincts
until I saw this I'm ready to get
crushed my friends I'm ready for people
to disagree tell me all the ways in
which I am wrong but this this actually
improves my opinion of AOC dramatically
there's a YouTube channel we're
partnering with that I would love for
you to check out it's a channel called
up flip you can get there by clicking
the link below make sure you subscribe
when you're there every week up flip
uploads a new video where you get an
exclusive behind-the-scenes look at a
different small business everything from
real estate firms coffee shops auto
repair shops each business owner shares
a ton of really interesting insight
about how they built their business what
it's like day-to-day how they got to
where they are fascinating to learn
about other people's business strategies
how they found success it's a great
channel for anyone thinking of starting
a business already running one or just
people interested in how different
business work perfect for people who
like TV shows like shark tank and that
type of thing check it out at david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
underneath the video they are friends of
the David Pakman show make sure to
subscribe when you're there click that
Bell icon to be notified when they
upload new videos